I'm Emily opera on physics writer for
science news so the big discovery this
past year was the detection of
gravitational waves and the LIGO
experiment and we expect to see more
from them in coming year so that's
really exciting everyone is super pumped
about gravitational waves right now we
could see more black holes coalescing
and creating waves that radiate out the
other thing like I might be able to
detect is emerging neutron star so when
these merge to create gravitational
waves just like the merchant black
hole's did but one exciting thing about
neutron stars is that when they merge
they might create light that we could
see if we can locate where that
collision happened and point telescope
said well particle physics is sort of in
a weird state right now it's it's a
little bit of people are starting to get
anxious because the Large Hadron
Collider is found Higgs boson but it
hasn't found anything else and we know
that there's a lot of stuff that's still
unexplained in particle physics like we
don't know what dark matter is the stuff
that makes up a large portion of the
matter in the universe so scientists are
starting to look in some more
out-of-the-way corners for new physics
so one of these experiments is called
the muon tree - to experiment that's
going to start taking data in 2017 so in
this experiment they look at muons which
are like heavy electrons they send these
muons through a magnet and they look at
the magnetic properties of the muon and
try to understand those the muon behaves
like a little bar magnet like it has a
north and a South Pole and that magnet
when it's in the magnetic field rotates
around it processes like kind of like a
top so what the miyanji - - experiment
is going to do is they're going to
measure the rate of that precession that
can tell you all kinds of things about
physics that we might not know yet we
might not understand
because this the the rate of this
procession depends on all these little
particles that are flipping in and out
of space and then quantum vacuum all the
time so it's the number that we measure
differs from the prediction that means
that there could be another particle out
there that we aren't aware of another
new experiment kicking off in 2017 is
something called the cold atom
laboratory they're taking a weird
quantum state of matter called
bose-einstein condensate and they're
sending it into space so a bose-einstein
condensate is the state of matter that
you get when you make atoms really
really really cold and they also take on
the same quantum state so they all kind
of behave as one and it's sort of like
they all become one with the board
physicists treat these bose-einstein
condensates like a playground they do
everything from studying the fundamental
laws of physics to simulating the early
universe or black holes the reason they
want to send this to space is because
you have to get a really cold and it's
space you can you can get it even colder
and you don't have to worry about the
effect of gravity pulling on your atoms
because you're in freefall at the
International Space Station this will be
the coldest place in the universe as far
as we know